This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm here with producer Chris Perube. Hey, Chris. Hey, Roman. How's it going? I'm doing good. So earlier this week, we heard your story about the Memphis pyramid, which is maybe
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我和制作人克里斯·佩鲁韦在这里。嘿，克里斯。嘿，罗曼。最近怎么样？我挺好的。这周早些时候，我们听了你关于孟菲斯金字塔的故事，那可能是
the strangest building in America. And it just got stranger and stranger the more we talked about it. But now you have this bonus episode for us. Yes. I have to justify the cost of staying in the pyramid hotel for three days. So I've created some extra material here. But before we start, okay, for folks listening, if you haven't heard the Memphis pyramid episode, do that first. Okay, this episode will only make sense if you've heard both. I mean, there's a couple of references that are pretty specific.
美国最奇怪的建筑。而且我们越聊它就越觉得诡异。但现在你为我们准备了这个彩蛋单集。是的。我得证明在金字塔酒店住三天的费用是物有所值的。所以我在这里创作了一些额外的内容。但在我们开始之前，好吧，对于听众朋友们，如果你还没听过孟菲斯金字塔那一集，先去听那一集。好吧，只有在两集都听过的情况下，这一集才能听懂。我的意思是，里面有一些非常具体的梗。
So I'd say go back and listen to that. But before we get into it, Roman, you actually know Memphis really well, right? What is your connection to Memphis? Yeah, my mom's family is from Memphis, and so I was sort of on and off growing up there. We lived in a different state most of the time, but I was there for summers and holidays. And then in my 20s, I lived there for a stretch delivering pizzas in midtown. And so I know Memphis very well. So listeners in Memphis, if you got a pizza delivered by Roman Mars and you want your
所以我建议大家回去听那一集。但在我们深入探讨之前，罗曼，你其实对孟菲斯非常熟悉，对吧？你和孟菲斯有什么渊源？对，我妈妈的家族来自孟菲斯，所以我小时候经常在那里进进出出。我们大部分时间住在另一个州，但我在那里过暑假和假期。后来在我20多岁的时候，我在那里住过一段时间，在中城区送披萨。所以我对孟菲斯非常了解。所以孟菲斯的听众们，如果你们曾收到过罗曼·马尔斯送的披萨，并且想要
money back, now you know where to reach us. So Roman, for my time in Memphis, I spent a lot of time in the pyramid, as we discussed. There was a whole day there where I didn't see sunlight. But I also spent a lot of time in the pyramid, as we discussed. There was a whole day there where I didn't see sunlight. But I also spent a lot of time with a guy named Jimmy Ogle. Now, do you remember Jimmy from the pyramid episode? Oh yes, he was perfect. Perfect Tennessee accent. Yes, he's our historian, right?
退钱，现在你知道去哪儿找我们了。所以罗曼，我在孟菲斯期间，正如我们讨论过的，花了很多时间在金字塔里。那里有一整天我都见不到阳光。但正如我们讨论过的，我也花了很多时间在金字塔里。那里有一整天我都见不到阳光。但我也有很多时间和一个叫吉米·奥格尔的人在一起。现在，你还记得金字塔那一集里的吉米吗？哦，是的，他太完美了。完美的田纳西口音。是的，他是我们的历史学家，对吧？
Like we talked to him, he used to be the historian for Shelby County, an instant fan favorite, in my opinion. And when I was working on this story, like a lot of people said to me, like you have to talk to Jimmy. He knows everything about the history of Memphis because of course he was a historian, but also he has like maybe the most eventful resume
就像我们跟他聊过的那样，他曾是谢尔比县的历史学家，依我看，他简直是个国民级粉丝最爱。当我正在做这个报道时，很多人对我说，你一定要和吉米谈谈。他了解孟菲斯历史的一切，因为他当然是个历史学家，但他也拥有我见过的
I have ever seen. Like here's just what he said when I asked him to introduce himself for the episode. Well, hi. I'm Jimmy Ogle and I had the privilege of working in downtown Memphis for 40 years in various public attractions like Mud Island and the Mississippi River Museum,
或许是最丰富多彩的履历。比如，当我请他在这集节目中做自我介绍时，他是这么说的。好吧，嗨。我是吉米·奥格尔，我有幸在孟菲斯市中心工作了40年，从事各种公共景点的工作，比如泥岛和密西西比河博物馆，
ran the Memphis Queen Line Riverboat Company, five passenger vessels, Beale Street, the operations of Beale Street, the Memphis Rock and Soul Smithsonian Museum about the history of Memphis music, the Beale Street Landing Project, landing the big river boats. I was a Shelby County historian.
经营孟菲斯女王号轮船公司，五艘客运船只，比尔街，比尔街的运营，关于孟菲斯音乐历史的孟菲斯摇滚和灵魂史密森尼博物馆，比尔街码头项目，停泊大型内河船只。我曾担任谢尔比县历史学家。
I gave walking tours up and down the sidewalks and PowerPoint presentations. Every day of the year, it seemed like. And my final job, I was duck master at the Peabody Hotel and a clock operator at the FedEx Forum for the basketball game. So I had a lot of neat things I got to do and great experience.
我沿着人行道做步行导览，还做PPT演示。似乎一年中的每一天都在这么做。而我的最后一份工作，我是皮博迪酒店的鸭子总管，以及联邦快递球馆篮球比赛的计时员。所以我做过很多酷炫的事情，也有很棒的经历。
I'm the luckiest Memphian ever to live. Oh my goodness, that's a lot. Right? It's usually when we do those, it's like, can you introduce yourself? It's like, I'm such and such and I'm a professor. Like that's it. But what a life, my gosh. You know, I probably understood more of those than the average person understood those little
我是活着的孟菲斯人中最幸运的一个。哦天哪，这工作量太大了。对吧？通常我们做那些采访时，就像是，你能介绍一下自己吗？对方就会说，我是某某某，我是一名教授。就像这样。但这是怎样的人生啊，我的天。你知道的，那些他做过的小工作，
jobs that he took. But let's talk about a few of them. So he says he was the clock operator for the NBA team? That's right, yeah, he ran the score clock for the Memphis Grizzlies. So he did that in the pyramid, and then he also did that once they moved to the FedEx Forum.
我可能比普通人理解得更多。但我们来聊聊其中的几个吧。所以他说他是NBA球队的计时员？没错，是的，他担任孟菲斯灰熊队的记分牌计时员。他在金字塔里做过这个，后来搬到联邦快递球馆后他也做过。
Yeah, and he ran Beale Street. I'm not sure what running Beale Street means. Yes, he was like the administrator of Beale Street. He was in charge of stuff, because there's lots of stuff. If you don't know Beale Street, it's the big tourist street in Memphis. There's lots of like blues bars, things like that.
是的，他还管理过比尔街。我不太确定管理比尔街意味着什么。是的，他就像比尔街的行政官。他负责各种事务，因为那里有太多东西了。如果你对比尔街不了解，它是孟菲斯主要的旅游街道。那里有很多布鲁斯酒吧之类的东西。
But there's also, you know, it has a bunch of historical markers. It has kind of their version of the walk of fame. Yeah, so he was in charge of all of that for a while. That's awesome. But my favorite one that you might've missed, if you do not know this history, is that he was the duck master at the Peabody.
但你知不知道，它还有一堆历史地标。它有点像是他们的星光大道版本。是的，所以他有一段时间负责所有这些。这太棒了。但我最喜欢的一个你可能错过了，如果你不知道这段历史的话，那就是他曾是皮博迪酒店的鸭子总管。
So this I have seen in action many, many times. I went to like a master at the Peabody. So this I have seen in action many, many times. I went to like a prom at the Peabody. When I go to Memphis, I like to stay in the Peabody Hotel. It's an older hotel that has a kind of like charm and majesty of it. You can have afternoon tea there. But the thing about the Peabody Hotel is they have ducks that live on the roof
这个我亲眼见证过很多很多次。我去过皮博迪酒店的毕业舞会。每当我去孟菲斯，我都喜欢住在皮博迪酒店。这是一家老牌酒店，有一种独特的魅力和威严。你可以在那里喝下午茶。但皮博迪酒店最奇妙的是，他们的屋顶住着鸭子，
and every day the ducks do this walk down to the fountain in the lobby. Yes. And then at the end of the day, they're walked back up with a person in like, you know, a fancy like coat and tails. And that's just amazing that Jimmy did that. That's just like, that is a one of a kind job. Yeah, I mean, it is considered like a high honor to be the Duckmaster. Yeah, I mean, it sounds like Jimmy has had every cool and interesting job there is in Memphis. Oh my gosh, no, it's amazing. And he is a true repository for like, all information about the history of Memphis.
每天鸭子们都会这样列队走到大厅的喷泉里。是的。然后在一天结束时，它们会在一个穿着（你知道的）那种华丽燕尾服的人的引领下列队走回楼顶。吉米竟然做过这个，真是太神奇了。这简直是一份独一无二的工作。是的，我的意思是，担任鸭子总管被认为是一项极高的荣誉。是的，听起来吉米在孟菲斯做过所有最酷、最有趣的工作。哦天哪，不，这太惊人了。而且他真的是个关于孟菲斯历史所有信息的宝库。
I got about 150 hours in my head I got to talk real fast and tell you about. So we're going to touch on some of them. But it's, there's no city in the world that tells a story of American history better than Memphis, Tennessee. So I reached out to Jimmy. We did the interview. We actually did the interview in my hotel room inside the pyramid. And afterwards he was like, you know,
我脑子里大概有150个小时的料，我得语速飞快地跟你讲讲。所以我们要触及其中的一部分。但是，世界上没有哪个城市能比田纳西州的孟菲斯更好地讲述美国历史的故事了。所以我联系了吉米。我们做了采访。我们实际上是在金字塔内我的酒店房间里做的采访。采访结束后他说，
what are you doing with the rest of your Wednesday? Like, can I give you a tour? Like he used to give these walking tours and he offered to drive me around. And I got about 10 hours of audio. Like he kind of took me everywhere. So Roman, today, I'm here to present you with the highlights from my tour of Memphis by Jimmy Ogle.
你周剩下的时间有什么打算？我可以带你参观一下吗？就像他以前带人进行这种步行导览一样，他主动提出开车带我兜风。我录了大约10个小时的音频。他基本上带我去了所有地方。所以罗曼，今天，我在这里向你展示吉米·奥格尔带我游览孟菲斯的精彩片段。
I picked out some of the 99 PI friendly greatest hits. Are you ready? I'm so ready. This is amazing. Thank you so much for doing this. Okay, let's do it. So Roman, I want to start with some kind of hardcore 99PI stuff.
我挑选了一些99号闭环（99PI）风格的热门精选。准备好了吗？我已经准备好了。这太棒了。非常感谢你做这些。好吧，我们开始吧。所以罗曼，我想从一些比较硬核的99PI风格的内容开始。
So when Jimmy was County Historian, he used to give a ton of walking tours, as I said, including a tour of Memphis manhole covers. Oh my God, it's like a dream come true for me. Okay, so yeah, let's hear it. So at one point we decided to stop and just like look at some manhole covers. One of the 157 different kinds of manhole covers in downtown Memphis out of 2000, by the way. Three different shapes, round, square, and rectangular.
所以当吉米担任县历史学家时，正如我所说，他经常带人进行步行导览，其中包括孟菲斯下水道井盖导览。天哪，这对我来说简直是梦想成真。好吧，那就让我们听听吧。所以有一次我们决定停下来，仔细看看一些下水道井盖。孟菲斯市中心有157种不同种类的下水道井盖，顺便说一下，总共有2000个。有三种不同的形状，圆形、方形和长方形。
Seven different usages, light, gas, water, telephone, traffic signal, storm drain, and communications. I love this man. I thought you might. So we're walking around and we stop at this one particular cover that Jimmy really wanted to show me So here here's a man a very ornate old manhole cover over a hundred years old Something Jimmy pointed out to me is how in Memphis the manhole covers all look different obviously and even on the same block You'll see a bunch of manhole covers that have completely different branding C Cumberland Telephone and Telegraph, okay?
七种不同的用途：路灯、煤气、水、电话、交通信号、雨水排涝和通信。我爱死这个了。我猜你会喜欢。所以我们四处走动，停在这个吉米特别想让我看的特定井盖旁。所以这里有一个非常华丽的老式下水道井盖，有一百多年的历史了。吉米向我指出的一点是，孟菲斯的下水道井盖显然看起来各不相同，甚至在同一个街区，
Here is Western Union Telephone Company. Of course, you can't see it with the audio here. You come way over here about, what, ten paces away, you have Memphis Telephone Company. Why would you have three different telephone companies' manhole covers within 20 feet of each other? Why? That's a of each other. Why? That's a very good question. Why do they have that? So it turns out these covers, they were for different local telecoms from about a century ago. And back then, if you signed up for a telecom company, you were only signing up for one service,
你也会看到一堆品牌完全不同的下水道井盖。坎伯兰电话电报公司，对吧？这里是西联汇款电话公司。当然，通过这里的音频你看不见。你走到这边大约十步远的地方，就会看到孟菲斯电话公司。为什么在彼此相距20英尺的范围内会有三家不同电话公司的下水道井盖？为什么？这是一个非常好的问题。为什么会有这些？事实证明，这些井盖大约是一个世纪前当地不同的电信公司的。在那个年代，如果你注册了一家电信公司，你只能使用一项服务，
and you could only call other people who had the same telecom. So they all basically just had their own infrastructure and that's what these manhole covers represent. The early years you had independent operators. So if you got a telephone at the turn of the century in the 1920s you had to pick one of three exchanges and you could only talk to the person on your exchange. So if your friends had Western Union but you had Cumberland you couldn't talk to them or you'd have to have two different phone sets or three to talk to all your friends had Western Union but you had Cumberland, you couldn't talk to them, or you'd have to have two different phone sets, or three to talk to all your friends. So of course, after the 20s, consolidation starts to happen, the system becomes more
而且你只能给使用同一家电信公司的其他人打电话。所以基本上它们都有自己的基础设施，而这些下水道井盖就代表了这一点。在早期，你们有独立的运营商。所以在世纪之交的20世纪20年代，如果你安装了一部电话，你必须在三个交换机中选择一个，并且你只能和同一交换机上的人通话。所以如果你的朋友用的是西联汇款，而你用的是坎伯兰，你就无法和他们通话，或者你必须拥有两部甚至三部不同的电话机才能和所有朋友通话。所以当然，在20年代之后，兼并开始发生，系统变得更加
regulated, and if you're in Memphis, you may still notice these manhole covers. They are the last vestige of the great Memphis telecom Wars. So obviously Memphis has a lot of history. Roman, you would know that coming from Memphis, that everywhere you go, you can't really avoid it. Yeah, a lot of it around music, a lot around civil rights. It's really like a place that's rich in history. Good, you know, both very good and very sad.
规范化，如果你在孟菲斯，你可能仍然会注意到这些下水道井盖。它们是大孟菲斯电信大战的最后遗迹。所以显而易见，孟菲斯有着丰富的历史。罗曼，作为孟菲斯人，你肯定知道，无论你走到哪里，你都无法真正避开它。是的，很多与音乐有关，很多与民权有关。它确实是一个历史底蕴深厚的城市。没错，你知道的，既有非常美好的，也有非常悲伤的。
Absolutely. Like the MLK assassination happened in Memphis, right? And you have a lot there commemorating that, but lots of joyful things as well, like Aretha Franklin's birthplace is in Memphis, for example. And the city really plays up the historical element with the street names. So there was a moment in the tour, so Jimmy's driving around, he pulls over,
绝对的。比如马丁·路德·金遇刺事件就发生在孟菲斯，对吧？你们有很多纪念它的东西，但也有很多令人愉悦的事物，比如阿雷莎·富兰克林的出生地就在孟菲斯。这座城市真的通过街道名称来彰显历史元素。所以在导览过程中有这样一个时刻，吉米正开着车，他把车停在路边，
and he says, look, we gotta see this intersection. And look, if we go up in here real quick and you jump out of the car, we're gonna let you take a picture at the intersection of King and King. Roman, do you you take a picture at the intersection of King and King. Roman, do you know what this is, the intersection of King and King? Yes, I think I do know what this is. This is the intersection of Martin Luther King and B.B. King Boulevard, I believe.
然后他说，听着，我们得来看看这个路口。听着，如果我们快速走到这里，你跳下车，我们让你在金与金交叉路口拍张照片。罗曼，你知道这是什么吗，金与金交叉路口？是的，我想我知道这是什么。我相信这是马丁·路德·金大道和B·B·金大道的交汇处。
That is exactly correct. And this is right downtown. And the two of them intersect, like it's a place where you actually see a lot of people pulling over to take a photo with the two street signs because they have basically the same name. It's King and King. It's only King and King intersection in the country. You go look that up too. A couple blocks away from this, there's actually another street which I am convinced actually is totally unique in the United States in terms of naming. So it involves your beloved Tennessee Valley authority.
完全正确。这就在市中心。这两条路相交，这是一个你真的会看到很多人把车停下来，和这两个路标合影的地方，因为它们的名字基本上是一样的。这就是金与金。这是全国唯一的金与金路口。你也可以去查证这一点。离这几个街区远的地方，其实还有另一条街道，我确信它在命名方面在美国绝对是独一无二的。它涉及你挚爱的田纳西流域管理局。
So on November the 6th, 1934, we voted to join TVA powers. They took this alley called Maiden Lane and made it November the 6th, 1934 Street. And right now you only see November the 6th on it, you'll see 1934. So the street is literally named November the 6th, 1934. Street. November the 6th, 1934 Street. Now, this is somewhat complicated by the fact that all the street signs there now just say November 6th Street. Apparently the city, to uncomplicate things, they published all these signs that say November 6th Street. It's a smaller sign, it's easier to read on maps.
所以在1934年11月6日，我们投票决定加入TVA电力。他们把这条名为“少女巷”的小巷改成了“1934年11月6日街”。而现在你在上面只看到11月6日，你看不到1934。所以这条街的名字字面意思就是“1934年11月6日街”。1934年11月6日街。现在，这件事由于一个事实而变得有点复杂，那就是那里的所有路标现在都只写着“11月6日街”。显然，为了简化事情，该市发布了所有写着“11月6日街”的标志。这是一个更小的标志，在地图上也更容易阅读。
But Jimmy insists it is still officially called November the 6th 1934 Street And he showed me all these photos of him with the old signs which used to say the whole day month year on it And if it is still November the 6th 1934 Street Then that would make it a very unique street name in America. Wow, that is amazing I mean, I mean this is back when the Tennessee Valley Authority was really rocking and great So so this is a good moment to commemorate and of course our show needs to continue our recent streak of TVA content
但吉米坚称它官方仍然叫“1934年11月6日街”。而且他向我展示了他与旧路标的所有这些照片，旧路标上曾写着完整的日、月、年。如果它仍然叫“1934年11月6日街”，那么这将使它成为美国一个非常独特的街道名称。哇，这太惊人了。我的意思是，我的意思是这是当年田纳西流域管理局真正如日中天、风光无限的时候。所以这是一个值得纪念的好时刻，当然我们的节目也需要延续我们最近对TVA内容的关注热潮。
But Jimmy noted something that just totally hadn't occurred to me and this might be the only street that is like this in America I cannot find anybody in 15 years to tell me different. You might be the one. This might be your golden moment here. It is the only street in America named after a month, a day, and a year. I'm going to look into this because I want to know as well. Well there's no July 4th, 1776 street in Boston or Philadelphia. There's no July 20th street in 1969 where we landed on the moon. When Memphis voted to join TVA power. And it's got to be some other dates in some other cities.
但吉米注意到了一件我完全没想到的事，这可能是美国唯一一条这样的街道，我在15年里找不到任何人能告诉我不是这样。你可能是那个例外。这可能是你的高光时刻。它是美国唯一一条以月份、日期和年份命名的街道。我要深入研究一下，因为我也想知道。波士顿或费城可没有“1776年7月4日街”。我们在月球着陆的“1969年7月20日”也没有对应的街道。孟菲斯投票加入TVA电力。其他城市肯定也有其他日期。
HOFFMAN Now, I looked into this as well and I couldn't find anything. I called a bunch of people, no success. So 99PI listeners, if you know a street close to you that is named after a day, a month, and a year, help us out. It'd be valuable for me. It'd be valuable for Jimmy Ogle as well. He would love to know if Memphis has the only street of its kind in America. We would love to know. We have more Memphis history after this.
霍夫曼：好了，我也查过这个，但什么也没找到。我给很多人打了电话，都没成功。所以，99PI的听众们，如果你知道附近有一条街道是用“日、月、年”命名的，请帮帮我们。这对我有价值，对吉米·奥格尔也很有价值。他很想知道孟菲斯是否有全美独一无二的这种街道。我们很想知道。稍后我们还有更多孟菲斯的历史。
So, okay. Speaking of streets in Memphis, Roman, Jimmy and I were out, we were walking in Memphis and we came to the most famous street in the city. What is that for people who do not know the city of Memphis? I'm going to say that's Beale Street. That I would wager that is Beale Street, yes. So very touristy stretch. They have the equivalent of the Walk of Fame with the notes.
好吧。说到孟菲斯的街道，罗曼、吉米和我当时在孟菲斯散步，我们来到了这座城市最著名的街道。对于不了解孟菲斯的人来说，那是什么地方？我要说那是比尔街。我敢打赌那是比尔街，是的。这是一个游客非常多的地段。他们那里有带有音符的“星光大道”的同款。
They have like music notes that commemorate people over there. And part of why we stopped there is actually because Jimmy just wanted to make sure the local historical markers were in good shape. So we were walking around and then he just started fixing them and we ran into the guy who currently runs Beale street and he's like, Oh yeah, go ahead, just fix some stuff. Oh wait, you actually brought it. You brought an Allen key?
他们有类似音乐音符的东西来纪念那里的人们。我们之所以在那里停留的一部分原因，其实是因为吉米只想确保当地的历史标志处于良好状态。所以我们四处走动，然后他开始修理它们，接着我们遇到了目前负责比尔街的那个人，他说：“哦，是的，去吧，随便修点什么。”等等，你居然随身带着它？你带了内六角扳手？
Hey, in the meantime, when you, after you tighten this up, what do you think after this, at some point I go through and see a lot of them there just working their self loose? So at some point our trip just became free labor by Jimmy. Anyway, Beale Street, one of the most famous streets in America, I would argue. And did you know it was actually renamed in the 1960s? I did not know that, no.
嘿，同时，当你、在你把这个拧紧之后，你觉得在这之后，在某个时候我走过去看到很多螺丝都在自己变松？所以有时我们的旅程就成了吉米的免费劳动力。不管怎样，比尔街，可以说全美最著名的街道之一。你知道它其实在20世纪60年代被改名了吗？我不知道，真的吗？
What happened? So it had been called Beale Street, but in the 50s, the city decided to change the naming conventions for all of the city streets. So everything running East West would become an avenue and everything running North South would become a street. So it became Beale Avenue because Beale was running East West.
发生了什么？所以它以前一直叫比尔街，但在50年代，市政府决定更改所有城市街道的命名规则。因此，所有东西向延伸的道路都将变成大道（Avenue），所有南北向延伸的道路都将变成街道（Street）。所以它变成了比尔大道（Beal Avenue），因为比尔街是东西走向的。
And it stayed that way for a while until a local celebrity got word about this. So a famous radio star named Danny Thomas, he was very famous at the time from Memphis. And Roman, can you imagine how Danny Thomas, this longtime Memphian, might have felt about this change? I can imagine somebody just taking great umbrage to changing the name of Beale Street. Oh yeah, he was absolutely furious about this. So he actually wrote a song called Bring Back My Beale Street, and he made 2,000 copies and he sent it to members of the city council.
这种情况持续了一段时间，直到当地的一位名人生得知了这件事。一位名叫丹尼·托马斯的著名广播明星，他在当时来自孟菲斯的知名度很高。罗曼，你能想象这位长期居住在孟菲斯的丹尼·托马斯对这个改变会有什么感觉吗？我可以想象有人对更改比尔街的名字感到非常生气。哦，是的，他对这件事绝对气炸了。所以他实际上写了一首歌叫《把我的比尔街还给我》，他印了2000份并寄给了市议会的成员。
So I'm going to play a bit of the song. The song is very spiteful. It's like, Sweet Beale Street, what have they done to you? I fell asleep on Beale Street. So the song comes out, and you can just imagine all the pressure this is putting on local politicians. So eventually, they cave in and they agree to rename it Beale Street. Well, there you go. Political action works. So Roman, after our trip to Beale Street,
所以我要放一小段这首歌。这歌非常赌气。就像是：“甜美的比尔街，他们对你做了什么？我在比尔街上睡着了。”所以这首歌发行了，你可以想象这给当地政客带来了多大的压力。最终，他们妥协了，同意把它改回比尔街。好吧，你看。政治行动是有用的。所以，罗曼，在我们去过比尔街之后，
we went over to the University of Memphis, which you may remember has the basketball team the famous Yeah, sure the fighting Tigers just the Tigers. But yeah, they were fighting. I guess they were fighting pretty hard in the 90s with any hard away So there's another very distinct feature of the university that Jimmy wanted to show me They actually have one of the few university programs in America that studies Egypt ology Yeah, well that makes sense because this is the city that's named for the capital of ancient Egypt. That's right. And outside the department there,
我们去了孟菲斯大学，你可能还记得那里有篮球队，那个著名的……对，当然是斗虎队，只是老虎队。但是，是的，他们在战斗。我猜他们在90年代凭借安芬尼·哈达威打得非常顽强。所以大学里还有另一个非常独特的特征，吉米想带我去看。他们实际上拥有全美少数几个研究埃及学的大学项目之一。嗯，这很合理，因为这座城市的命名就源自古埃及的首都。没错。在该系外面，
there is a 25-foot statue of the pharaoh Ramesses II. And actually, it's a perfect replica of a statue that existed in Egypt. Now, Roman, if you're going to build a replica statue of this, what material would you use to make something this big and imposing? I would imagine it's a concrete statue, a reinforced concrete statue. Yeah, that's what I thought too. It's a great guess and from a distance that's really what it
那里有一座25英尺高的法老拉美西斯二世雕像。事实上，它是埃及真实存在过的一座雕像的完美复制品。现在，罗曼，如果你要建造这样一座雕像的复制品，你会用什么材料来制作这么大、这么宏伟的东西呢？我想这是一座混凝土雕像，钢筋混凝土雕像。是的，我也这么想。这是一个很好的猜测，从远处看它确实
looks like. But Jimmy took me up real close. It looks like the real deal. I mean that's Ramsey standing there in a majestic mood. He wasn't attacking anybody. He was just standing in the guard over Egypt. You know, look at the hands and look at that. He wasn't attacking anybody. He was just standing in the guard over Egypt. You know, look at the hands and look at that thing. He's just gladly standing there. This, you know, this... Hear that? That's hollow. So Roman, it's a very convincing dupe, but the statue is actually fiberglass. Did you not know it until you knocked on it? No, I thought it might be concrete or stone or something. It was very convincing. Right.
看起来是这样的。但吉米带我走得很近。它看起来就像真的一样。我的意思是拉美西斯以威严的姿态站在那里。他没有攻击任何人。他只是站在那里守护着埃及。你知道，看看手，看看那个。他没有攻击任何人。他只是站在那里守护着埃及。你知道，看看手，看看那个东西。他只是高兴地站在那里。这个，你知道，这个……听到那个了吗？那是空心的。所以罗曼，这是一个非常逼真的赝品，但雕像是玻璃纤维的。你敲了它才发现的吗？不，我以为它可能是混凝土或石头之类的东西。它非常逼真。对的。
And it's funny because the statue actually wasn't constructed for the university. That's not where it lived for the longest time. It was actually in front of the Memphis pyramid originally. And it was displayed in front of there when it was a basketball arena. And it stood there until 2012. And after that, Bass Pro moved in and they decided, okay, we're going to move the statue. City Council had a vote and they decided to send the statue to the university.
有趣的是，这座雕像其实并不是为这所大学建造的。它在那儿可没待最长时间。它最初其实是在孟菲斯金字塔（Memphis Pyramid）前面。当它还是一个篮球馆时，它就陈列在那里。它一直立到2012年。在那之后，巴斯商店（Bass Pro）搬了进去，他们决定，好吧，我们要搬走这座雕像。市议会进行了投票，决定把这座雕像送给大学。
So now the University of Memphis rents the statue. They have this 99 year lease with the city where they pay $1 a year to rent the Ramesses statue and they keep it in front of their apartment. That's a pretty good deal. I would pay for that. But just another pyramid connection with in front of their apartment. That's a pretty good deal. I would pay for that. But just another pyramid connection with the rest of the city. I know. It's just everywhere you go in this town, they have Egyptomania still.
所以现在孟菲斯大学租用了这座雕像。他们与市政府签了99年的租约，每年支付1美元来租用拉美西斯雕像，并把它放在他们的系部门前面。这真是一笔不错的交易。我会为此付钱的。但这只是与城市其他地方的另一个金字塔联系。我知道。在这个城镇里，无论你走到哪里，他们依然有着“埃及狂热症”。
Love it. So Roman, our biggest visit of the day, this was to a part of town called Mud Island. Did you ever go to Mud Island? I have gone to Mud Island. I know exactly what that is, But it is hard to explain. So why don't you describe Mud Island? And you took the tram over, I take it? We've got to talk about the tram, actually. So here's the thing with Mud Island. You know, Mud Island, it's actually a misnomer. It's actually a peninsula, technically, on the
太棒了。所以罗曼，我们今天最大的一次参观，是去了一个叫泥岛（Mud Island）的城镇部分。你以前去过泥岛吗？我去过泥岛。我完全知道那是什么，但它很难解释。所以你为什么不描述一下泥岛呢？我想你是坐电车过去的吧？其实我们得谈谈电车。所以泥岛的情况是这样的。你知道，泥岛，这其实是一个用词不当的名字。从技术上讲，它实际上是密西西比河上的一个半岛。
Mississippi River. And for a long time, Jimmy was the manager at Mud Island. So he was in charge of all the attractions that were there. It has this public park, right? It has this amphitheater. But Roman, unfortunately, a lot of the stuff there today is abandoned. So 5,000 people would come out this walkway here. Yeah.
在很长一段时间里，吉米是泥岛的经理。所以他负责那里的所有景点。这里有一个公共公园，对吧？它有一个露天剧场。但是罗曼，不幸的是，今天那里的很多东西都被废弃了。所以会有5000人通过这条人行道出来。是的。
Turnstiles, the permanent seating was 4,400. There was bleachers on this top level. I had the concession stands built outside the walls. So they have this amphitheater. It hasn't been used for concerts in a couple years now. And the island has this scale model of the Mississippi River. And Roman, do you remember this? You could sort of walk along it and follow the path of the Mississippi. It's totally worth checking out. I saw it. It's still there. And of course, Mud Island has the River Museum, which was this museum dedicated to the city of Memphis.
旋转门，固定座位有4400个。顶层有露天看台。我把小卖部建在墙外。所以他们有这个露天剧场。它已经好几年没有用来办音乐会了。岛上有一个密西西比河的比例模型。罗曼，你还记得这个吗？你可以沿着它走，追踪密西西比河的路径。非常值得一看。我看到了。它还在。当然，泥岛还有河水博物馆（River Museum），这是一个致力于展示孟菲斯市的历史博物馆。
And Roman, I knew about this before I came to Memphis. I think you can guess why, because it's from a movie that you have probably seen as someone who is from Memphis. Oh, you mean the firm. Yes, it's the firm. Yeah, yeah. I know he's chased around downtown Memphis, so does it pass by here?
罗曼，我在来孟菲斯之前就知道这个。我想你能猜到为什么，因为它出自一部你可能看过的电影，作为一个孟菲斯人。哦，你是说《糖衣陷阱》（The Firm）。是的，就是《糖衣陷阱》。对，对。我知道他在孟菲斯市中心被追着跑，它经过这里吗？
They do. So basically there's this scene in the firm where Tom Cruise, you know, he's this big shot Memphis lawyer, he's being chased around by goons, and they chase him to Mud Island on this monorail that's running over to the island. Right, right. So he's being chased around this famous museum, the Memphis River Museum, but unfortunately the Memphis River Museum actually closed because of low attendance in 2018, and they also stopped running the monorail.
它们确实。基本上《糖衣陷阱》里有这样一个场景，汤姆·克鲁斯，你知道，他是孟菲斯的大人物律师，他被一帮打手追着跑，他们把他追到了泥岛，坐着开往岛上的单轨列车。对，对。所以他在这个著名的博物馆——孟菲斯河水博物馆周围被追赶，但不幸的是，孟菲斯河水博物馆在2018年因参观人数少而关闭了，他们也停止运营单轨列车。
So now the monorail is just sitting there. It's next to this unused building that has more than 30,000 square feet of space. But do they have any plans to do anything with it? Well, it's funny because remember we talked about the pyramid as this case of adaptive reuse, right? Like it was an arena and then it became a Bass Pro, right? And throughout Memphis, there are a lot of cool projects like this I'm noticing, a lot of good adaptive reuse
所以现在单轨列车就那样闲置着。它旁边是一座未使用的建筑，拥有超过3万平方英尺的空间。但他们有什么计划用它做点什么吗？有趣的是，还记得我们讨论过金字塔作为适应性再利用的例子吗？就像它以前是个体育馆，后来变成了巴斯商店，对吧？在整个孟菲斯，我注意到有很多这样酷的项目，有很多好的适应性再利用
that's been happening. So there's this old Sears warehouse, which has become this massive community center. There's lots of old office buildings downtown that have been converted into housing. And with the River Museum, there are people recently who've moved in and are starting to clean it up. Drywall's been replaced, the walls have been painted, but there's still a lot of junk. So that's Marvin Stockwell. He's leading the redevelopment project of the old River Museum. We've been given access to an immersive by design museum space that snakes back in on itself,
一直在发生。所以有一个旧的西尔斯仓库，已经变成了巨大的社区中心。市中心有很多旧办公楼被改造成了住宅。至于河水博物馆，最近有人搬进来开始清理它。干墙被更换了，墙壁被粉刷了，但里面还是有很多杂物。那是马文·斯托克韦尔（Marvin Stockwell）。他正在领导旧河水博物馆的重建项目。我们获得了一个沉浸式设计博物馆空间的权限，它向内蜿蜒盘旋，
33,000 square feet, and there are two full-size boats in there. So we were given a space that, like, if you're a commercial developer, you're like, what the hell are we going to do with this space? But you turn it over to artists and they're like, I'll tell you what we're going to do with it, right? So today, Marvin's working with artists and designers and video game developers, and they're turning it into this immersive experience, like there's going to be big video screens and like a sci fi plot and kind of this D&D like game you can play. So Catherine Hicks, she's one of the developers on the project. And here's how she described it to me. Think of the Millennium Falcon ride in Star Wars, but more observation deck style. So the look and feel will kind of be like this very steampunky, very like 20,000 leagues under the sea.
有33,000平方英尺，里面有两艘全尺寸的船。所以我们得到了一个空间，如果你是一个商业开发商，你会想：我们到底要用这个空间做什么？但你把它交给艺术家，他们会说：我来告诉你我们要用它做什么，对吧？所以今天，马文正与艺术家、设计师和电子游戏开发商合作，将其变成一种沉浸式的体验，比如会有大的视频屏幕、科幻情节以及那种你可以玩的龙与地下城（D&D）式的游戏。凯瑟琳·希克斯（Catherine Hicks）是该项目的开发人员之一。她向我这样描述它。想想《星球大战》里的千年隼号游乐设施，但更像是观景台风格。因此，外观和感觉将有点像这种非常蒸汽朋克、非常像《海底两万里》的感觉。
I mean, that's amazing. It sounds incredibly ambitious. It is. And I mean, there's a huge renovation happening in the space right now. And for this project, to keep the costs affordable, they are reusing a lot huge renovation happening in the space right now. And for this project to keep the costs affordable, they are reusing a lot of the features in the space, which of course includes these two full-size boats from when it was the River Museum. — Rehearsal. — Rehearsal. — Okay, here we go, here we go. — Give me your ear. I know I'm a serious reporter, Roman, but I was not above ringing the bell and feeling
我的听众朋友们，这太棒了。听起来雄心勃勃。确实如此。我的意思是，这个空间现在正在进行大规模的翻新。为了这个项目，为了保持较低的成本，他们正在重复利用空间中的许多特色……（插入排练声音）……好吧，我们开始吧，我们开始吧。——听我说。我知道我是一个严肃的记者，罗曼，但我忍不住去敲响那个铃铛，感受
delight at ringing the bell. But it's really interesting. It's another reminder that I saw all over Memphis and that I really felt in the pyramid that the life of buildings is long, right? And we never know what's going to end up in a particular space. I find it delightful. In terms of adaptive reuse, it seems like an incredibly big change. Did Jimmy, our historian, feel like the loss of something or just kind of excitement about
敲响铃铛的喜悦。但这真的很有趣。这再次提醒了我，我在整个孟菲斯随处可见，而且我在金字塔中真实感受到的，建筑的生命是很长的，对吧？我们永远不知道最终会有一个什么样的空间。我觉得这令人愉快。就适应性再利用而言，这似乎是一个极其巨大的改变。我们的历史学家吉米，是对失去某些东西感到某种失落，还是对
what was happening? He's actually the one who brought me here. So he was enthusiastic that something was moving in, right? And I feel like he had this really good attitude about how spaces change and how cities change. I mean, how do you feel seeing, like, knowing what it was and seeing what it's becoming like? I'm over that. I mean, you know, like when you have an old friend who passes away, you're sad for the passing, but it was a good long life. And after you get over the tears, you
正在发生的事情感到兴奋？其实是他把我带到这里的。所以他对有新事物进驻感到很热情。我觉得他对空间如何变化以及城市如何变化有着非常好的态度。我的意思是，看到它以前是什么样子，再看到它变成现在这个样子，你有什么感觉？我已经看开了。我的意思是，你知道，就像你有一个老朋友去世了，你为他的离去感到难过，但他度过了美好而漫长的一生。等你擦干眼泪之后，你
start telling stories about each other and it turns into a giggle fest at a funeral. You know, it's a celebration. So you know, to celebrate the 40 years that it was there, I feel like this is an attitude that sometimes I can lose sight of when talking about buildings and change in cities. And I just think this is a really healthy attitude to have. I think it's a great reminder for all of us about all kinds of things. This is really fantastic, Chris. Thank you so much for bringing me back to Memphis.
开始讲述彼此的故事，葬礼最后变成了咯咯的笑声。你知道，这是一场庆典。所以你知道，为了庆祝它存在了40年，我觉得这种态度有时我在谈论建筑和城市变迁时会忽视。我只是认为这是一种非常健康的态度。我认为这对我们所有人来说都是一个关于各种事情的绝妙提醒。这真的很棒，克里斯。非常感谢你带我回到孟菲斯。
I really appreciate it more than you know. Roman, it was a real pleasure and I hope one day they get the monorail running again. I'd like to nominate us to be the first to take a ride on it because I really want to see the monorail in action. I will meet you there in a heartbeat. Thank you. Thanks, Roman. This bonus episode was produced by Chris Barube and Isabel Angel. Mixed by Martin Gonzalez. Music by Swan Real and Mia Byrne. Fact checking by Laura Bollins.
我真的非常感激，超乎你的想象。罗曼，这真的是我的荣幸，我希望有一天他们能让单轨列车重新运行。我想提名我们成为第一批乘坐它的人，因为我真的很想看看单轨列车运作的样子。我一秒钟都不会犹豫就会去那里见你。谢谢。谢谢，罗曼。这期特别节目由克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）和伊莎贝尔·安杰尔（Isabel Angel）制作。马丁·格雷扎莱斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音。音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）和米亚·伯恩（Mia Byrne）创作。劳拉·博林斯（Laura Bollins）负责事实核查。
You can find a list of Jimmy Ogle's tours and special events on his website, jimmyogle.com. That's jimmyogle.com. That's jimmy-o-g-l-e.com. Special thanks to Louis Graham and the team at Baron von Opperbein and the River of Time. They're the ones building an immersive experience at Mud Island. We'll have a link to their project on our website. Kathy Tu is our executive producer.
你可以在他的网站 jimmyogle.com 上找到吉米·奥格尔的旅行团和特别活动列表。网址是 jimmyogle.com。即 j-i-m-m-y-o-g-l-e.com。特别感谢路易斯·格雷姆（Louis Graham）以及巴伦·冯·奥珀拜因（Baron von Opperbein）和时间之河（River of Time）团队。他们是在泥岛上打造沉浸式体验的人。我们将在我们的网站上提供指向他们项目的链接。卡蒂·图（Kathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人。
Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的资深编辑。团队其他成员包括杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·雷（Vivian Ley）、拉什马·唐（Lashma Dawn）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg），还有我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99%可见的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。
We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心上城区潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。你可以在Blue Sky以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有指向该链接以及99PI过去每一集节目的链接，网址是99PI.org。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。